[Music]
what's up guys it's a chain of j-1 of
the head instructors of Krav Maga
Academy Krav Maga is a self-defense
system design in Israel for the
respective forces today we're gonna try
the bottle cap challenge I'm going to
explain to you what this kick is really
about it's pretty much it goes down to
the silicon roots shotokan karate roots
you have to first start off with the
basics
nobody kind of rotate that hip that kick
how do you how to snap that kick how to
use your hip to really put that [ __ ]
into it as well if you want to use more
than more Thai style cakes alright guys
so we did the bottle cap challenge I
want to challenge myself a little more
I'm gonna try a blindfolded want to
sense where the bottle is with my mind
while my eyes are closed and try to do
this again
we're going to see how much force this
bottle kick challenge kick actually has
so we're gonna try that kick
military-grade dummy and aim for his
face right over here so let's try that
kick
[Music]
I want to try it with the non-dominant
side my dominant side my right leg I
want to try it with my left leg by
setting it up with the rear roundhouse
kick Oh kind of like that
my buddy ray agreed for me to do this on
him in real life so we're gonna see how
much damage this actually does he's
gonna be funny because he's going to go
like on the floor
[Music]
in a fight I probably would not use it I
would stick with the basics real house
cakes cakes
on a real street fight situation if you
really want to protect yourself in a
fast manner really want to blast that
guy and recommend the rear little kid
straight to his knees or to his IT band
you just want to smash that IT band part
over here or take out his knee it looks
like this watch